deine identität dein name deine bilder
eingesetzt von betrügern um illegal an
geld zu kommen
kriminelle nutzen die korona krise vor
ganz neue betrügereien betrüger greifen
privatperson an unternehmen ganze
staaten verbrecher wittern ein großes
geschäft mit der korona krise
ich würde mal behaupten das war der
digitale bankraub des jahres definitiv
der gesamtschaden noch nicht genau zu
beziffern
doch es geht um viel geld auch wir
werden angegriffen und bekommen eine
phishing-mail wir drehen den spieß um
und wollen herausfinden woher kommt die
mail
wer sind die betrüger
wochenlang bewegen wir uns in verdeckten
foren im internet
treffpunkte von kriminellen es herrscht
goldgräberstimmung unsere werte
bundesregierung stellt rund eine halbe
billion euro für finanziell durch corona
geschädigte firmen zur verfügung
die frage ist also wie schneiden wir uns
ein paar scheinchen davon an die
verbrecher attackieren auch uns online
wir bekommen eine e mail auf unserer
arbeits adresse angeblich vom
arbeitgeber zdf de darin werden wir
aufgefordert den anhang zu öffnen was
würde passieren wenn wir sie wirklich
öffneten von berlin aus sprechen wir mit
einem spezialisten in münchen
wir haben fälle wo sich dann die
angreifer mit eine aktive
zahlungsvorgänge mit 1 kriegen das heißt
die überweisung gibt nicht auf das konto
von dem geschäftspartner sondern auf
irgendeine bank muss sie dann auf
nimmerwiedersehen verloren ist die
zahlung haben die angreifer das bei uns
versucht wollten sie in unsere
bankverbindung eingreifen
wir wollen wissen woher der angriff
kommt steinmeier verspricht die e mail
zu analysieren in der zwischenzeit
versuchen wir dorthin zu gehen wo die
kriminellen sind in die tiefen des
netzes das sogenannte deep web der
zugang hat findet einen digitalen
untergrund marktplatz im angebot drogen
waffen und geklauten kreditkarten die
verkäufer agieren die geister nicht
sichtbar
versteckt hinter crypto technik reden
sie über betrugsmaschen in corona zeiten
ich meine jeder nutzt die krise um seine
taschen etwas zu fühlen
habt ihr da was im kopf wir schreiben
viele foren nutzer an wo er besser
verstehen wie der betrug funktionieren
soll
eine antwortet sein deckname fehling
tempel
ich arbeite gewissermaßen hauptberuflich
als betrüger und das seit jahren
bin aktuell an einer größeren sache geht
wohl um staatliche zahlungen kredite was
genau dahinter steckt weiß ich noch
nicht ich bin jemand der nur ein konto
stellt und das geld wischt verlinkt herr
bösch der konten zur verfügung mit denen
andere die herkunft von geldern
verschleiern
die sie meist illegal erwirtschaftet
haben das geld landet also auf gefakte
konten angelegt mithilfe geklauter
identitäten die betrüger nennen das bank
drops wie funktionieren diese fake
konnten nach langen vorgesprächen ist
ein cyberkrimineller bereit uns zu
treffen anonym
in einem hotelzimmer er erklärt wie sie
an die identitäten der opfer kommen
wir schalten feld webseiten mit
jobangeboten in den job angeboten haben
wir bei der schriftlichen bewerbung um
einreichung des ausweises gefragt
angeblich für die erstellung eines
arbeitsvertrags und so habe eine seiner
seiten ausgesehen
hier wird ein screenshot des
personalausweises abgefragt mit diesen
daten wird dann der bank drop erstellt
das heißt wir stellen so ein bankkonto
und verwalten das unter dem namen ohne
dass sie davon wissen
in deutschland können online konnten nur
noch mit einem sogenannten video ident
verfahren eröffnet werden
die betrüger manipulieren diese
verfahren wenn man die leute dahin
gehend bearbeitet die video ident
verfahren zu machen da gibt man sich als
jemand aus der man gar nicht ist
die betroffenen haben lange keine ahnung
dass ihr konto dazu dient kriminelles
geld zu waschen
meist fliegt der betrug nach vier wochen
auf es lohnt sich offenbar trotzdem
unser informant beziffert den schaden
den er angerichtet hat auf rund zwei
millionen euro
er seit 2009 10 ausgestiegen als eine
gruppe ins visier der fahnder geriet
wollten betrüger auch an unsere
kontodaten
unser it experte thalmeier aus münchen
hat unsere e mail analysiert die
rückschlüsse die wir aus aus aus dem
angriffsmuster ziehen können ist dass
diese gruppe eine semi professionelle
bande ist also eine kriminelle gang wenn
man so will
kaymers analyse zeigt die angreifer
agiert mit einer portugiesischen
ip-adresse und wir sind nicht die
einzigen potenziellen opfer 3600
menschen gerieten ins visier der
kriminellen
die korona krise ist ein willkommener
anlass für cyberkriminelle schnelles
geld zu verdienen
die versuchen von der unsicherheit zu
profitieren auch unser kontakt filling
tempel ist offenbar involviert
er schickt uns ein chat protokoll er und
ein unbekannter tauschen sich aus wie
die korona abzocke ablaufen soll
villingen tempel soll für die täter geld
waschen und das möglichst schnell bevor
öffentlichkeit und behörden es bemerken
betrifft überweisungen ab 8.000 name des
empfängers egal
1,4 millionen payments zeit das geld mit
der methode
das soll so spielt public werden wie
möglich ok klar
also ich schaue dass ich morgen weitere
bank drops klarmachen 15.000 sind raus
gerade bestätigung erhalten
montag dienstag ist das da ich hab dich
mit geld zu das glaubst du nicht sieben
tage nach diesen chat ist klar worum es
ging
offenbar haben betrüger eine masche
gefunden die sofort hilfen vom staat
abzukassieren
tausende anträge seien missbräuchlich
gestellt worden die linke schickt fotos
sie belegen es wurde tatsächlich geld an
ihn überwiesen 9000 euro absender ist
corona bezirksregierung düsseldorf
und so soll der betrug gelaufen sein
also die daten für die soforthilfen
werden über eine fake seite abgefasst
quasi eine seite die aussieht als ob man
da sofort hilfe beantragt dort werden
empfindliche privat und firmendaten
abgefangen
dann wird mit denselben daten aber eben
einer anderen iban der antrag bei der
richtigen behörde gestellt und wie viele
insgesamt also es ging am ende knapp
4.000 anträge durch aktuell werden die
meisten zahlungen gestoppt bzw
da kommt nichts mehr aber das lief ja
schon einige tage gut ich würde mal
behaupten das war der digitale bankraub
des jahres definitiv
und was ist ihre rolle ich selbst wasche
diese über drei bis vier andere konnten
wechseln sie in bitkom
diese bitcoins werden gemixt um die
herkunft zu verschleiern
ich erhalte den betrag schließlich als
guthaben auf einer anonymen sim-karte
die gefälschte website über die der
betrug lief ist mittlerweile gesperrt
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt zum
aktuellen verfahren keine auskunft
oberstaatsanwalt markus hartmann
bestätigt aber dass kriminelle so
vorgehen wie unser kontakt feeling
tempel ist beschrieben hat die
kriminellen gehen arbeitsteilig vor die
einprogrammieren webseiten andere wie
unser kontakt für den tempel stellen die
bankkonten zur verfügung
bestimmte richtung kann man fast sagen
spezialisieren sich auf das entwickeln
von schad-software die nächsten auch das
anbieten von bankkonten über die
zahlungen geschleust werden
drittel haben besondere fachkenntnisse
der website programmierung und über
marktplätze im internet vor allem in dem
bereich findet dann diese
unterschiedlichen spezialisierungen
zusammen und ermöglichen damit fiel zwar
auch erst eine professionelle
tatbegehung wie viele millionen der
korona häfen von kriminellen kassiert
wurden wird sich erst in den nächsten
wochen zeigen ein ende der masche
scheint nicht in sicht
fehling tempel meldet sich ein letztes
mal gruß am rande aber einen hinweis
dass das mit den krone hilfen noch geht
es heute einen beleg über 15.000
angeblich diesmal nicht aus nrw
mittlerweile wurde bekannt betrüger
haben auch in sachsen berlin und anderen
bundesländern soforthilfen abgezockt hat
ihr schon mal betroffen von cyber
kriminalität schreibt es in die
kommentare
frontal ab sofort erscheinen hier auf
dem youtube-kanal von zdf heute
nachrichten regelmäßig unsere recherchen
abonniert den kanal um keine zu
verpassen
[Musik]